so many people say no and it's just like
dating you just need one person to say
yes hi I'm Emily Matai ed I'm the
co-founder of Haven Li and I'm 28
Haven Li does online interior design so
for a flat fee of $1.99 per room will
design your space for you and you can
actually buy all the furniture through
us as well so really it's just like
curated approach to the furniture
ecommerce space one of the biggest
things for us is every single designer
that's on our platform is trained and
vetted and it's accredited so it's not
as though it's an online marketplace per
se all of our designers are Haven Li
designers and that means a very high
quality
[Music]
I moved into my first big-girl apartment
in New York I was in consulting and it
was just so insanely difficult to put my
space together even though I had a
pretty decent budget no traditional
interior designers work with me because
you know my budget was still small and
even they were too cost-prohibitive my
co-founder who happens to be my sister
was also facing the same thing she'd
moved into her house with her husband
and really it just made no sense why
nothing like this existed why people
weren't democratizing into your size
[Music]
my father's an entrepreneur he was an
immigrant came here with very little and
it's just one of those things that you
see someone who can take these business
ideas and constantly thinks about them
and apply complex solution sets work
that's how I grew up being able to take
a macro view of a career in
entrepreneurship
having that perspective has been very
[Music]
truly I wish I wasn't so mean and
heart-to-heart uh myself I think the
biggest thing I've learned in the past
five years is just be kind that you're
kind everyone tells you to be kind to
everyone else but learn how to be kind
to yourself because that'll make the the
journey a lot easier
you